we got this here from Fox News Kevin
McCarthy breaks with McConnell will
oppose 1.7 trillion dollar Omnibus Bill
McConnell and said Republicans have
voted to support the bill so we have
Jake Sherman tweeting GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy will attend the Senate up
steering lunch today to make the case
against the Omnibus 20 Republicans voted
to proceed to the bill yesterday and the
Senate GOP leadership is supporting the
package
I gotta say look I'm not I'm not the
biggest fan of McCarthy people have been
complaining that he was funding he was
putting up money to stop populist
candidates but clearly the pressure
campaign on his speakership is making
him at least move away this Omnibus is
complete another garbage for one reason
now I know Rand Paul came out and he
said epic viral video where he was just
ripping it apart I could only say this
because I was because I was watching the
Kerry Lake trial I didn't get a whole
lot of it the only thing I did
understand was that Rand Paul called it
he said outright it's going to be the
18th or 19th we're gonna get a 5 000
page spending bill that we're not going
to be allowed to read and then they're
going to expect us to sign it and this
is what they're doing right now
apparently there's funding for corporate
media in this I've been seeing people
talk about there's a whole bunch of
garbage it's 1.7 trillion
it's a total Destruction of the American
dollar it's spending money that they
don't have on crazy issues and things
that absolutely make no sense at all I
looked in some of the details here it
looks like there's going to be money
allocated from your money from American
taxes or just devaluing your money to
secure the border of Pakistan and
Lebanon in order to have recruitment for
women in police forces in South and
Central America gender programs in
Pakistan and there's also an allocation
for 2.6 billion dollars in order to fund
the prosecution of the January 6th
domestic terrorists according to CNN
that's their reporting of it but but
again this is only what what we're
seeing now no one still hasn't really
read the full list as of course it's
4155 Pages some of the worst people in
politics have gotten together and said
you know what we're just going to write
ourselves a blank check you can't even
read what's in there this should be
absolutely criminal and they're going to
add absolutely tanked the US economy and
spend money on on gender programs in
Pakistan this is absolutely bewildering
this is out of touch with reality and if
there ever was a conspiracy theory that
came true about the great reset and
destroying the American way of life in
the American middle class this is the
perfect example I just did some math the
U.S debt right now is 31 trillion so if
we're going to print another 1.7 that's
1 18th of our national debt that means
that we're devaluing the Dollar by 1 18.
of its own value which is like four
cents your dollar is not going to be
worth after if this goes through your
dollar's worth 96 cents that's all fake
dude you're a dollar worth 96 cents but
if you go back to pre-jacko Island your
dollar's worth like point zero zero one
cent right when you start to do the math
you see the compounding diminishment of
the value at the purchasing power of the
US dollar keeps going down dramatically
almost every few years and when you look
at it from even the 1960s it is an
absolute debasement it is an absolute
destruction I mean we are reaching
levels of Myanmar Germany we are
reaching levels of what people saw in
Zimbabwe of what people saw in Venezuela
there's no going back from this this is
Banks just printing zero on the computer
just clicking zero zero zero zero zero
zero giving it to all their buddies all
their friends this is the sinking ship
and this is them taking all the silver
out of the ship and making sure that
they're able to have it for themselves I
feel like there's people are trying to
sync the ship so we could remove the
ballast I agree there's no going back
there's no paying off the debt but we
could default on the debt very good
point they blew up the ship now they're
taking the silver from the ship and now
they're they're on their life but that's
what I've been saying it's like the
Titanic hits the iceberg and instead of
telling the people on the ship they're
running and grabbing as much silver and
stuff in their pockets as they make
their way to the the lifeboats and the
memers are playing the music and that's
right enjoying some kind of semblance of
reality we know it's happening and we're
standing there just rocking out like oh
we're going down but uh I guess my
question is then we're watching this
happen with this Omnibus spending bill
what do you do if let me tell you a
story there was this viral viral story a
few months ago where it was like these
people inherited a house from their
grandfather and then they popped open
one of the floorboards in the attic and
they found a case with like fifty
thousand dollars in it and they were
like this is amazing and it was fifty
thousand dollars from like the 1950s and
I was like bro that was like a million
bucks back then so if they're if their
grandfather bought gold or some other
hard asset and hid that instead of US
Dollars they'd be millionaires and
what's happening is the people with a
lot of money are buying gold and hard
assets because there's no real estate as
well exactly I've never done the
property that they would have now and
the people that aren't able to afford
hard assets right now are the ones that
are at the bottom of the Ponzi scheme I
don't know how to help them other than
like if we did default to the National
the Federal Reserve very least we say
we're not paying you back the interest
on our debt which would probably cut 15
trillion I don't know how much of the of
the debt is interest but if we were to
say we're not paying any of it back
Private Bank you've been screwing us for
100 years it's over uh the it would
Bannon and Steve Bannon asked him on
stage in America Fest the other night if
that would be ethical and he said yeah I
said would it destroy our our standing
around the world and you know but I mean
it was that was vague it wasn't we
weren't specific getting into it I need
to get more economists involved with
what would actually happen to the the
U.S the new currency if we were to but
he said if we don't force debt
sovereignty a sovereign debt collapse
that it's going to happen to us against
our will in a way that we don't want so
we may as well take it by the horns and
make it happen from from my perspective
we are seeing the deliberate destruction
of the American Petro dollar we have
seen Saudi Arabia position themselves
closer and closer to China uh
establishing more relations with them we
just saw the Indian Central Bank had
come out and warning that it was
cryptocurrencies that allegedly could
trigger the next financial crisis what
we saw with Sam bankman freed what we
saw with him moving around billions of
dollars from the bank of Ukraine working
with the world economic Forum working
with of course American politicians
funneling all that money there I think
we have a perfect scapegoat that will be
Bitcoin that will be cryptocurrencies
that will be decentralized currencies
that will be taken down by these Central
Bankers that will then introduce the
Central Bank digital currency and with
that to social credit score this is a
long game that they've been after for a
very long time and they will stop at
nothing at trying to achieve that this
is the current reality that we're
dealing with and I think the more we
wake up to it the more we realize it the
more we could actually try to stop it
but right now when these big Central
Bankers are are causing so much damage
what can we really do that's the big
question that I think a lot of people
should be asking themselves right now
this feels like the perfect story for
for Ian and Luke who are ragging on the
fed the whole time I just don't know if
Kyle has any thoughts on like Financial
policy or anything like that but you
know what do you think man I'm 19.
so what kind of stocks and bonds do you
have what's your retirement Kyle please
tell us Kyle crypto what Bitcoin are you
in what crypto are you sorry I'm just
bust I'm just I you know I tried crypto
I tried crypto for a little bit I don't
really understand it at all I will be
completely honest I honestly am so lost
in the conversation
um I was too in crypto but that's why I
asked I'm like it's like Luke and Ian
just go back and forth we could keep
going meaning could keep ranting also
just one last caveat here Sam Bank me
freed by the way will likely be moved to
the same prison that Jeffrey Epstein was
uh taken out of so the story is going to
become hidden Circle very soon no that's
not the joke yes those are the reports
coming in right now as he's being
extradited to the United States as we're
speaking right now but but Kyle just
more in general to kind of ask you here
to to put to bring you in with this
conversation financially what are you
seeing from your perspective you're 19
years old you're still young but you
know what what are you seeing with uh
savings money how people are are
treating their money are people people
going out and partying and going crazy
with their money or are they saying hey
times are really tough
you know some people I know like I know
a lot of kids my age I live in a college
town and I see a lot of people that just
go out and party I stay at home I'm
facing a civil lawsuit right now I
really don't have the money to go out
and do all these things that people my
age are I dipped into a cryptocurrency a
little bit I don't understand it I
bought a coin I made like 80 bucks off
of it yeah there you go the market
crashed and I was like oh this is going
down and I was using coin by base I said
I was going down why no oh no no okay
sorry go ahead we'll talk after yeah FTX
right Luke no
centralized exchanges hold your own Keys
People For Goodness Gracious please
goodness I'm sorry go ahead Bill almond
suggested that when you use the uh the
networks like big like coinbase and
binance that you treat them like public
restrooms you go in do your business you
make your trade and then you put it back
on your own that's a good analysis
public restrooms yeah you don't want to
hang out there and see what gets smeared
on very bad people very very bad
politicians hang on in public restrooms
and they do very bad things that they
were as they were previously caught
doing before but I won't get into that
story sorry
you were saying Kylie
but uh you know I pulled out
um I collected my 80 bucks I made from
it and
you gotta pay taxes on that now oh 15
yeah I got to pay taxes 15 to 30 I did
not know that yes well it's still like
crazy the tax law and the crypto because
no one knows what's happening like it
all of a sudden they talk about
inflation 31 trillion in US Dollars how
about the inflation the crypto inflation
that just happened over the last 10
years what's the real Global Currency
number right now they say the market cap
of crypto is only 2 trillion but I mean
you know it just feels like the whole
machine about to explode okay with the
Twitter files we've got so much coming
out Twitter files eight the FBI I think
it was the FBI right or who was a
military intelligence engaging in
psychological operations pretending to
be middle easterners we we've actually
known this story going back to I think
it was 2011 or 2012 with uh it was um I
think it was Barrett Brown who did uh
what was the name of their project PM I
think it was and they exposed that U.S
military was were buying sock puppet
accounts fake accounts to do
psychological operations we now have new
uh developments from Twitter the fact
that we know that and it came because
Elon Musk bought Twitter it feels like
the whole facade is crumbling you look
at how they're spending money we're off
the fractional Reserve banking policy
we're on to infinite Reserve Banks can
just make whatever amount of money they
want give it to whoever they want the
system is just gutted and it feels like
they know it everything's about to
collapse my question I guess is is it
intentional you know I think you were
who was just saying Ian were you saying
that like if like it's not doing it on
purpose if they weren't trying to
destroy the economy and Rob the middle
class of their wealth what would they be
doing differently I think that's the
question that a lot of people need to
ask themselves thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time